so can you go back to the top countries
to do business with and look at the top
minimum wage because we've been talking
about minimum wage we talked about a
little bit with norway
and the debate is norway capitalistic
nation a socialist nation
so let's go to the top minimum wage
countries is that the one or no
this is one of them yeah okay so so if
you uh
number one is that luxembourg luxembourg
okay what website is this
worldpopulationview.com
okay go to the other one go to the other
one because that number seems lower than
what australia
is uh luxembourg has the highest minimum
wage in the world 13.78 13.78
okay uh uh uh uh
well that would only go to luxembourg oh
it's the same website okay so
go back to the website he had luxembourg
australia
what was the other website that said
1260 australia 12 so i saw one that says
19 but it's mostly
19 australian dollars oh i got it i got
it so australia
cents their minimum wage france 1166
by the way you're looking at socialism
right there then you got new zealand
1120 which was number one on business
friendly
business friendly 1120 then you got
germany 1087
then he got netherlands 1044 belgium
1038 uk 1034
ireland 962 canada 952 fyi china
russia is two dollars and forty cents
okay can you go a little lower mario
just to see
the us has the twelfth highest minimum
age in the world at 7
25 at 7 25. it's important to see at 725
right okay
so if us goes to 15 bucks an hour
which numero uno in the world numero uno
in the which by the way looks like it's
gonna happen
because of the 1.9 trillion dollars the
democrats control the house the senate
and presidency and
uh you know it's going to be easy for
that to be done minimum wage goes to 15
bucks an hour
if minimum wage goes to 15 bucks an hour
and all the other countries we're
beating are socialistic countries what
does that say about america
[Laughter]
makes you think to say if there's an
area you don't want to lead is
minimum wage it's like look how amazing
we are we pay the highest minimum wage
go ahead two things with the minimum
wage i see australia is number two i
went to australia
2009 so a little over uh 10 11 years ago
and i remember uh obviously i got to
australia i landed i meet up with a
buddy
let's go get a beer let's go get a beer
let's go have a drink cool all right i'm
in the land down under i'm about to have
a beer
and uh we you know my i'm staying with
my buddy so
you know i do the right thing i pick up
the tab and pick up the check cool
guys yeah i know breaking news picked up
the tab i picked up the tab there it was
guys have you ever seen adam pick up the
tab yes actually yes
a cup once but what is this percentage
i mean with me it's very good but then
again but
but how many rides yeah who's the driver
so that's the exchange you're going to
play the pro quo that's good that
doesn't that doesn't
apply to everybody else no i'm just
lucky we roll with pbd and pvp host
everybody how many times have people pay
for pat anyway where's my egg sandwich
anyway
um mario's also very cordial what's my
point here what's my point where i wish
we had the button here
so i go to pick up a chat it's a hundred
year uh australian bucks whatever
and i go to leave a tip and the guy goes
no no no no
you don't you don't you don't need to
live a tip they're already good i'm like
what do you mean
in america you got a tip 20 percent you
know my bill's 100
bills 100 bucks you leave the waiter you
know bartender 20 bucks whatever he goes
no they're already very well compensated
i said what do you mean
they go yeah they make 20 bucks an hour
i said you're telling me
the waiters and the servers and the
bartenders make 20 bucks an hour
you don't need to tip them no you don't
need to tip them i said very interesting
so it's
that's just a quick story and we can get
a feedback but here's my
here's my segue back to pat you know
because i would consider myself much
like mario an entrepreneur i've helped
build businesses but i'm not the
business owner i'm not the founder i've
built built up a business and made a
business very successful but i'm not the
owner
same thing we're doing here with
valuetainment but we were reading
yesterday about the
15 minimum wage hike that's going on
here and potentially in america
and and pat said how do you feel about
that i said you know look i'm i've come
out vocally i'm not in favor
of a federal mandate of a 15 minimum
wage
i think that's absurd across the board
in certain states or cities
new york city san francisco miami
whatever cool i get it
you can't live on less than 30 grand a
year if you're going to have
a life but if you're in tuscaloosa
alabama if you're in
you know bumble f oklahoma like
businesses you know i don't i'm not in
favor of that
so i that was my perspective and i asked
pat your perspective and genuinely pat
says
i am so sad
i feel so bad for these businesses you
have no idea how
bad i feel for the i'm i i'm genuinely
hurt for these businesses
and my thing was more logical zero
emotion
in my answer i said well i just don't
think it makes sense economically
financially
pat came from a place of obviously logic
first and foremost
but deep sympathy for these businesses
and i said i don't
feel that sympathy that you're feeling
and you said well that's because you've
never started your own business
i said what do you mean by that and you
said when you start a business
you know you now you know maybe this is
where you want to pick up
but you had very strong feelings about
this minimum wage it was more like it
was more emotional than logical how'd
you feel
well you know listen go to
go to the example i gave you when i said
adam let's just say you and i fight
no because you went to say when a person
starts a business don't they already
know that you may lose it yeah that's
because that's what the conversation was
i said you put your
you know you risk everything to kind of
put yourself out you know what you're
getting yeah you know what you're
getting yourself into and i said
yes except when the rules change that's
when it's unfair so if you and i were to
fight there's a big fight coming up
yeah patrick's fighting adam on june
28th major announcement you're a better
buyer
i'd pay for you're a better person
you're a better boxer you're a better
boxer you're an eight i'm a six and a
half i have no clue how to box
but you're a much better boxer than me
much better fighter than me
and the rules is we're going to fight
what boxing
but i'm a ridiculous kicker if i kick
you you're over three kicks
fight's over okay that's me i'm a nine
you're a one when it comes down to
kicking
five minutes before the fight they say
rules have changed you cannot kick
who wins that fight i win the fight
because i don't even have to come close
to you i can't have a distance from you
my legs are longer than your punch so i
won the fight okay
so you're married you're on a small
market
that your father passed down to you you
and your husband run it together with
your kids it's been around for 80 years
in a small city
and you have walmart right across the
street but you've still been able to
survive because walmart sells milk for
359
you sell milk for 349. they raise the
minimum wage
six of your employees that work for you
you pay them 720.
okay eight of your workers i worked you
pay them 720. some of them 10 bucks an
hour but not 15.
so they raised the minimum wage to 15.
you have to raise the milk price from
349 to 429.
walmart keeps it at 359. you
have to raise the employee's minimum
wage from 720 from 10 bucks an hour to
what
15 bucks an hour walmart doesn't care
walmart loves that
the government officially eliminated you
without walmart becoming the enemy
a 15 minimum wage makes
the small business owner go out of
business without walmart even needing to
compete
right walmart says it's cool like it's
like the fight happens and the referee
said fight hasn't even started referee
says
adam you won and what are you talking
about we haven't started adam won the
fight that's over
that's what just took place right now
think about it this way okay
minimum wage what
industry pays the most employees minimum
wage
let's look at it do we have that data we
don't have that data okay
pull up the data wait uh there's one
which is the uh
no we might actually not have this one
but we have the chart uh if you go
here one that says here the tab that
says here
where is here okay right there okay good
you'll see here are
this is for leisure and hospitality
that's not what i'm looking for i'm
looking for can you search mario which
industry has most minimum wage employees
by the way the number is staggering
the difference between first place and
second place makes zero sense
which in the audience want to guess what
industry oh you can guess
while we're pulling this up you're about
to be shell-shocked
which industry has most minimum
wage let me see if i can find it more
you do it as well employees see if you
can find it i know i searched it
yesterday
uh and it was a okay now
oh my gosh if we can show you this this
is okay i found it here we go
i find it's a statista website uh
can i share it with you airdrop or
you're not on a mac you're on a mac okay
airdrop
which mac are you on i have it's
valuetainment media
like tim and mack is that the one yeah
okay mario see if you receive it
you got it okay i'm gonna press it again
okay open it up accept watch this look
at this
look at look at that not even close get
rid of that
beautiful
oh there you go okay go up a little bit
it's not letting you see the uh
are you kidding me because i have it
over here okay well anyways you see that
first one
i'll just tell you what it is you see
the first line the first line is leisure
and hospitality yeah
you know what the second one is
education 977
by 149. seven times higher
okay so let me get this straight leisure
and hospitality
has the most employees making minimum
wage and
which industry got crushed
during covet the most the last two years
you just
crushed these guys yeah you just
destroyed them and if you go to the
last chart you can see what jobs have
lost the most mario bring up where the
jobs are
um another interesting part though is
that that is also the industry where
people are most tipped and leaders
so that obviously makes up for their
wages in that sense of that there's a
there's the there's the minimum wage and
then there's the tips they receive as
well
everybody took a hit with that the
customer because food price is going to
go up
it's going to go down tip's going to go
down food prices are going to go up and
what's that uh here the one the tap to
the left for that mario
i got that one leisure and hospitality
they are down the most in january i mean
they've been crushed the entire pandemic
but even january
they lost the most jobs so you know it's
like imagine you're running a small
restaurant you're like okay oh we're
going to come back
oh my gosh we have 38 000 in our account
babe
we're going to make this work guess what
minimum wage so then imagine that
meeting with you and your employees
your waiters and your waitresses you're
having a meeting with them you got four
of them sitting in front of you
how do waitresses feel about the minimum
wage being raised from 725 to 15 bucks
how do the waiters and waitresses feel i
mean well
how many are sitting there there's four
four of them well now congratulations
i've been with you for five years
there's only three of you now someone's
getting but actually give me their
feeling
how are they feeling about going from 7
25 to 15 bucks
exactly they're not against it they're
for it are you kidding me dude
what are you talking about do you not
remember what like i had a job for 325
at haagen-dazs
when i got a race to 5 15 at bob's big
boy i'm like dude i'm going to be
rolling getting a nice freaking telestar
pager and i'm going to be able to send
the hello text and the double beeper you
know all this stuff it's going to be
sick right from 375 325 to 550.
if your waiters and waitresses are
sitting there for them they're going
from 7 25 to 15
minimum wage you think they support the
minimum wage hell yeah hell yeah they do
you think you the business
owner that now have to sit there and say
guys we got to do something about this
do you think there's a division now
between the employer and the wages
i mean compensation-wise at that point i
feel like they're also dipping into tips
at that point you can't or legally you
can't do that you can't do that
legitimately no no no you can't
you mean really you want the restaurant
to take tips off you can't do that
you you one restaurant gets reported
that the owner keeps tips
you're over nobody works for you
obviously you're not doing not taking
the hundred percent but you're making
enough for not to do
anything really you cannot do anything
it is the fastest way to not have
waiters and waitresses work for you is
what
is when you keep tips a percentage of
the tips it's the fastest
i think the house twice as much it
doesn't matter that's not how things
work
that's not how things work so guess what
they pulled the title a typical burger
you go to a nice restaurant a burger's
what 15 16 bucks
a nice restaurant i'm not talking about
like you go to burger king
nice restaurant you go to like what
gary's is that gary's what is that place
we go to here right here we were there
yesterday with the crispy zucchinis
gary's uh uh gary's farmhouse right here
in boca by uh meisner
his burger is uh 16 bucks 17 bucks
they raised the minimum wage his burger
is now 20 at least 22 bucks
23 bucks ain't nobody paying 22 bucks
for a burger
soda is a buck fit or you will pay for
it no you will
i mean the businesses as well you won't
pay for it whoever's covering your
check will pay for it but someone's
paying for it
22 burger at what point is that just
ridiculous it's not about instead
ridiculous you have no control this is
not something they're asking you for
your vote the senate the house and the
president's passing this law
and they're putting it in the 1.9
trillion dollar bill you don't have a
choice you don't have a say
just take it this is what's happening
here okay so yes that's what's going to
happen
leisure and hospital as if they didn't
have one black guy they just got a
second black guy
i saw something on uh prageru on their
instagram uh
they did a little bit where it's like
all right guys congratulations there's
four of you in the room
and uh major announcement uh
minimum wage has been increased up to 15
so let me tell you what's going to
happen to the four of you uh john
congratulations you have a raise
sally congratulations you ever raised
nancy congratulations you have a raise
bill pack your [ __ ] time for you to go
bud you got to go
so the four has gone down to three and
the
the rest of you will just be doing more
work uh for
uh 15 an hour and congratulations on
everybody on their uh
new jobs and uh get the hell out of here
yep yeah by the way
somebody just said here right now they
said pbd it's called gratuity and they
do it all the time
dante i know i get that and this one
person said florida has had a
15 minimum wage florida has 15
minimum wage in a couple of years it's a
done deal anyways meaning the 15
minimum wage right yeah you must have
missed yesterday's podcast though
you must have missed yesterday two days
ago podcast i said states like florida
texas california new york forget about
it 15 bucks is it's
mandatory what are you talking about
thirty thousand dollars a year for a job
it's nothing
that's how much you're making on fifteen
dollars an hour just times you buy two
this
isn't about florida america is bigger
than florida california new york and
texas
yeah america is bigger than that all
over all of the flyover states that
everyone forgets about
concerns my concern is a small market
you know how when people say things like
the argument is
well do you think it's fair that a
company like walmart came and crushed
all the small businesses and put them
out of business
yes they didn't do it by themselves they
did it with the help of the government
regulations yeah they did it with the
help of government that's that's how
they do it they didn't do it intended
they got some help to have some like
that take place so yes i am with you and
i hope some of these businesses
find a way to survive specifically in
the leisure and the hospitality so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you